aimez vous c'était il ya vingt ans et il
ya 20 ans le portrait la bea est le
portrait de greg le millionnaire sur tf1
où je rappelle qu'il s'agissait d'un
beau gosse donc riche et musclé qui
avait pour mission non c'est faux de
trouver sa future femme parmi un panel
de candidats très jolie dans une sublime
maison à ibiza les prétendantes ignorait
tout de lui et de sa fausse vraie
existence
regardez le bruit est un garçon simple à
la recherche de l'amour il rêve d'une
vie meilleure quand soudain il va
échanger sa vie modeste contre une vie
trépidante de multimédia d'un jour le
portier autres secrétaires particuliers
désormais riche il doit apprendre les
codes de son nouveau monde
avant que greg le millionnaire ne
rencontrent ces vins prétendantes est la
première rencontre grégory doit faire
face à une avalanche de questions
certaines filles s'intéressent déjà à sa
fortune génériques
d'autres au contraire porte plus
d'intérêt à sa dissentiment
compétitrice tél
trouvera-t-il celle qu'il
[Applaudissements]
a capté complètement par hasard en fait
à l'époque je dansais souvent dans des
émissions de télé ouais et j'aime pas de
danseurs qui me branche pour un casting
j'arrive dans le casting il a joué avec
un journaliste en face de moi qui me
correspondent à une demi heure des
questions et je me dis bon c'est
forcément pour eux un pour l'émission de
télé réalité mais je sais pas du tout
pourquoi j'y allais dans quoi je
m'engageais alors l'émission démarre
gauche ou non mais il ya vingt ans
c'était hyper fort de se dire on va
faire venir vinci pour qui drague avec
mon père fortuné si on prend le recul
sur la chaussée quand même on à mettre
20 peu riches
moi j'ai su le concept de l'émission à
une heure avant de signer le contrat
avec angela d'accord c'est chiant à
l'émission démarre faut quand même se
rappeler que c'est des scores cédé 6
millions est sûre nous faire une époque
louis tu deviens une énorme star et la
panique a tf1 on découvre un que tu as
un casier judiciaire et deux que tu as
tourné des films un petit peu érotique
oui on va dire tu as in érotique d'une
opération pardon regardez un extrait
[Rires]
sur la découvre ça là qu'est ce qui se
passe et quand je dis ouais et
branle-bas-de-combat la tour de tf1 mais
ça s'est pas passé comme ça en fait
c'est moi qui ai prévenus angela
llorente pas d'accord la productrice je
l'apprécié beaucoup et que je voulais
pas lui faire un enfant dans le dos à
dix jours de l'émission et je lui ai
expliqué que j'avais eu des semaines
faute et dont je rappelle que je parle
tu vas rire
c'est à nîmes il m'a répondu à tes
inquiète pas - chérie ça va bien se
passer d'accord edouard que c'était le
branle bas de combat à la tour bouygues
web avec gérard louvin avec avec tous
les patrons de tf1 et puis qui ont fini
par dire ce que je dis ce que je disais
depuis le début que j'étais un joli
exemple de reims assurant que tout le
monde avait le droit de faire une
connerie de sa vie absolument on peut
dire qu'on peut dire là maintenant tu
étais au bar à côté de nouvelles villes
mais à l'époque le casier c'était quoi
trafic de stups tout à fait d'accord
trafic de stupéfiants effectivement pour
tf1 c'est quelque chose il te garde
émission mission je crois que
tout le monde a regardé si je peux dire
comme la plus puissante et deco mais moi
quand tu sortais des dossiers plus les
dès maintenant de téléviseurs avec
marjolaine alors justement les
prétendantes ta chérie ça va être
marjolaine non non c'est marie qui a
alors
rien ici ouais je suis jeune je n'ai pas
fait partie des finalistes marjolaine
est arrivée loin c'est toi qui choisis
ça est viré envoie les parties en cinq
ans cinquième avant la fin je crois
c'est que vous l'aimez pas beaucoup
d'argent qu'il aime pas beaucoup nous
chassent que je peux pas dire que je
n'aime pas il y avait une séquence de
même j'ai besoin de toi j'appelle ça
peut aller mais c'est pas ça sakho 6
toujours envoyer des piques mais au fond
c'est pas une méchante fille j'ai rien
contre elle alors puisque tu ne dis pas
je veux dire je n'ai aucune nouvelle des
ça m'intéresse pas je n'aime rien à
[ __ ] d'elle je t'avoue mais on essaie
de tout la merveille à la série 200
brasse ça me fait rire vingt ans après
il faudrait qu'elle passe à autre chose
la petite elle a dû mûrir j'espère
depuis jean laherrère complètement mais
vous parlez plus du tout pour vous était
fâché mais j'ai mis ce qui fâche ira t
elle concrètement on est peut-être l
mais moi je n'ai jamais été vrai nom
elle n'avait pas été très sympa l'avait
dit sur une émission sur europe 1 avec
laurent mbassi que que greg n'était pas
hyper brillant hyper intelligente si
respirer pas là
on a hâte et robin marjolaine plusieurs
fois et marjolaine m'a dit quand je suis
arrivé dans la maison moi pardon pour
tf1 mais moi j'ai reconnu la maison
c'était la maison d'un ami donne de nets
pardon j'avais passé mais voilà c'était
la mise à la maison de mon aïeule
auditionné situation même le débat donc
j'ai le premier prime elle sait que tout
défaut que c'est que tout est faux c'est
quand même hallucinant et benoît je ne
savais aussi qu'il le savait as tu sais
quel est ce que par hasard j'étais tombé
sur son ex le propriétaire de la villa
dans cette maison
c'est moi j'étais enfermé dans la base d
une maison témoin c'est même très connus
et
non mais de toute façon margelle on l'a
tout de suite vu quand elle est arrivée
elle chercher la lumière une fois que
l'élève ou les squelettes a baissé à toi
mais moi je vais
contacter a été une star gigante j alors
l'émission cartonne ça se termine et là
derrière il ya plein de choses pour toi
qui souffrent notamment la chanson oh
non ça c'était bien après c'était la
plus grosse connerie
[Musique]
oh
je dois faire comme ça
[Musique]
des jeunes il y en a 400 tr pas
j'imagine que tu as tu as plein plein de
propositions j'en ai eu j'ai été parfois
bien conseillés parfois un peu moins de
biens j'ai eu un gros regret c'est quand
angela llorente m'avait proposé de
présenter l'île de la tentation en fait
ouais et gérard louvet remet avait un
petit peu interdit de le faire en fait
d'accord et c'est le plus gros regret
que j'ai eus parce que depuis là je
pense que j'aurais pu continuer une
vraie carrière d'animateur et et les
mauvaises décisions on en a tous
présents les mauvaises décisions c'est
quoi un c'était surtout sur bosses et de
me lancer dans la musique alors que
j'étais pas fait pour ça c'était plus
actif qu'autre chose en fait c'était
plus un délire qu'autre chose et la
ferme célébrités c'est une mauvaise
décision pour toi ou pas ah non je me
suis régalé s'était régalé
c'est que quand elle était en bout de
piste quoi ah non mais je me suis
rarement je te prends pour qui j'étais
bien pas toi jéjé l'image que ça donnait
pour les gens qui étaient dedans l'image
que les gens que les journalistes volant
de données c'est pas mon problème à moi
je me suis je me suis éclaté j'ai passé
une super expérience ouais j'aime me
canoy des drogues illégales est arrivé
troisième avec une super aventure ou en
afrique ce que j'aurais jamais
l'occasion de revivre je pense à ce
point là quoi et alors après c'est
génial après c'est assez hallucinant
c'est que tu dis qu'après c'est un peu
plus compliqué il les jours avec des
jours sans soit l'argent et tout ça
c'est le moment où tu perds un tout
petit peu et là je les ai gros mots et
ne gagnera j'ai eu des gros mots en
galère c'est quoi les grands moments de
galère c'est un des moments où tu fais
la ferme ta 100 mille euros qui vont
rentrer en semaine comme herbin brut on
va dire on va presque 100 millions en
brut et quoi mais c'était il ya
longtemps
en bout de piste au total cent mille
euros j'ai fait sans que la charia
jusqu'à la fin j'ai fait la finale
j'arrivais à paris sur le plateau on et
sortira donc en minéraux et des semaines
on avait un salaire qui serait aussi un
truc de clément où tu touches ça et puis
après il faut vivre avec pendant un an
ou deux puis quand tu avais un peu
déconné mais les impôts ils sont bien
servir et magie ça va très vite et puis
tu as les périodes où tu prends beaucoup
tu en a d'autres où tu prends moyens et
ma vie ça a été beaucoup comme ça
pendant longtemps et puis c'est
compliqué j'imagine comme benoît et sa
cote a annoncé compliqué de travailler
dans la vie de tous les jours non parce
que ça du tout meilleur gp le cheval a
fallu que je j'ai monté une boîte j'ai
monté une autre boîte j'ai tenu un
restaurant était un gros bosseur quand
même mais j'ai changé ou une boîte est
obligé wathier oblige et puis en même
temps c'est quelque chose qui me
passionne j'ai toujours été dans la nuit
je suis dj j'aime la musique
électronique et j'aime faire danser les
gens
dans la nuit maintenant tu es dans le
matin puisque je me lève très affinée
pour un dock et c'est extrêmement mignon
aujourd'hui tu te voilà tu t'es poser ta
rencontre ta femme ornella qui est une
ex miss ile de france elle est
magnifique elle avoue 2 c'est formidable
tu as deux enfants avec et comme tu le
dis voilà avant je me couchais à 7
heures du matin je me lève à 7h du mat
pour les déposer et on peut voir des
enfants ouais j'ai deux enfants moi mais
on y en avait un troisième qu'elle me
fait le beau papa va très bien bagarré
il est 7h30 et comme tous les matins
chez les basses eaux c'est la course
car grégory 40-50 est à présent père de
matteo
livio et s'occupe d'hilario le fils de
sa compagne ornella un mannequin
ancienne miss de beauté rencontrés en
france il ya six ans désormais véritable
papa poule ces journées sont calibrés
sur celle de ses enfants parce que ça
pardonne pas de matane c'est surveillé
j'en avais et fois drainé un petit
déjeuner avalé à la hâte de respect vous
allez les enfants on y va on se bouge un
peu
terrible c'est quoi ta vie aujourd'hui
tu vis ou et c'est quoi ta vie je vais
la réunion depuis trois ans et demi
et
avec mes enfants mais pourquoi la
réunion parce qu on est là vivait là-bas
ou par non et quitter la france elle
voulait aller l'un des pires moments de
pascal et son frère qui vivaient là bah
ouais et quand même avait suivi - de feu
à perpignan dans ma boîte et qu'on peut
dire qu'on voulait bouger ans elle
voulait aller au soleil j'ai fait allez
on y va et puis voilà on est là-bas
depuis
je fais de l'événementiel en ce moment
un peu moins mais j'ai fait beaucoup
l'événementiel j'ai tenu des restaurants
pendant un petit moment d'accord moi
j'ai tenu j'ai été directeur de sortie
étaient parents des vacances des séries
j'ai surtout été l'année c'est une
connerie ça vous fait un bon match et
l'accord des anges
c'est quoi je suis parti seul et je me
suis plu je me suis dit que ça devait
être à la réunion à la base et après tu
verras la réunion à la base c'est moi
qui avais trouvé le plan des maisons et
tout et puis ça a été annulée suite au
scandale et cent mille sabords
c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup moins vécu mais la nature mais
je me suis quoi
c'était trop et est
une question grecque parce que moi je me
souviens j'étais beaucoup croisé les
années qui ont suivi greg le
millionnaire et je te croise en soirée
en boîte ce que tu faisais mon travail
des conneries aller à la recherche de
gens connaissent guère à chaque fois que
je les croisais je leur parlais c'est ce
que je faisais avec greg et à chaque
fois ce qui m'a marqué c'est que tu
avais toujours un nouveau projet c'est à
dire que tantôt tu voulais être comédien
puis chambre j'avais déjà fait gelé tout
se passait super bien j'ai fait ma
question c'est est-ce que tu regrettes
pas de peut-être pas focalisé peut-être
sur ou un truc c'est à dire soit la
comédie sur la musique soit l'animation
je suis allé rejoindre parfaitement
notre dans mon gros problème en fait
c'est que suis pas allé au bout des
choses quand j'ai commencé un truc je
suis pas allé au bout des choses j'étais
un peu fou fou et je me suis je me suis
pas mal diversifier mes mails tous qui
sait tout ce qui est théâtre comédie les
séries que j'ai fait c'est super bien
des trucs qui vont arriver dans pas
longtemps les grecs avant la question de
benoît jusqu'aujourd'hui enfin très
content est-ce que c'est titi est ce que
tu aimerais revenir mais je veux revenir
en france de tous meilleurs délais
prévus dit à ma femme là la rentrée
toute manière je vais être en france en
moins sur deux titres que tu aimerais
faire président ou des charges d'un
projet qui a rien à voir je vais monter
un glamping de luxe
de luxe
jeanne à s'exécuter
le projet qui est en train de monter là
que j'espère sera ouvert au mois d'avril
de l'année prochaine d'accord mais à
côté de ça j'aimerais bien mais
chez nous non moi aussi j'ai rien à
aussi chroniqueur voilà je viens en
train de penser à ça pourrait rentrer et
puis refaire un peu de talent il dit
aussi quoi ouais c'est vrai une foire
gosse un peu hétéro sa mangue sa feuille
de route mais ça manque un peu
non mais c'est vrai que j'y pense à
sébastien elma bien j'aimerais bien
ouais c'est pas bête du tout alors
attention c'est pas sympa cent mille
balles
pour le fun via le 20 mai benoît non
c'était pour en revenir à ce que tu
disais tu sais pour nous les candidates
et l'arrêté c'est pas facile de faire
des choix de carrière à ce compte il
faut bouffer on nous propose un peu de
théâtre présente un peu si un peu
moniker un peu animé faire des
discothèques des bouquets et on te dis
souvent pour l'image les gens qui sont
au dessus c'est pas ça c'est pas bon
pour moi attends un peu mou l'informant
faut bien bosser si tu veux faut bien
bouffer que nous vous de moi mais qui
pour nous sont dits oui mais là tu as
fait un mauvais choix oui mais j'ai fait
le choix de bouffer en fait et puis ces
gens là qui tourne tandis de faire ce
truc là bas ils te lâche toi ils
partiront et donc des métiers dit merde
aujourd'hui le faire peut-être les
consignes
et antoine ils ont bossé il a beaucoup
plu louvain qui prenait un petit peu là
quand tu arrives à paris tap à bout
s'était pas pris une ride dans la rue
j'ai alors on s'arrête et on s'arrête
encore ses photos ses machins toi me
reconnais apprécier les gens sont sympas
ils sont sympas mais ma question c'est
est qu en tête et greg le millionnaire
dont tout le monde atteint tel
personnage comme l'écrit le noah a
vraiment fait route derrière compliqué
non compliquée si d'un tas de cette si
c'est compliqué c'est que c'est
compliqué dans ta terre parce que tu
peux faire ce que tu veux tu peux aller
bosser n'importe où c'est une question
d'ego c'est une question d'envié ou à la
question non après l'été a été
particulière parce que c'est quand même
un peu on a quand même fiancée wynn a
été au second degré sa parodie ça c'est
un piège dans une taie réalité c'était
pas comme ce qui a pas vu ton d'exemple
que sa selle a été bien fait
l'été a été génial l époque qui était vu
par beaucoup de monde ah ouais je garde
vraiment tête et des chroniqueurs abba
j'aimerais le alors je ne te promets
rien vont passer par cyril hanouna la
chaîne lionel stade on vole à ma soeur
tout ça il ya beaucoup de monde
suit le dernier maillon mais moi pour
mon maillot ça me ferait très plaisir en
tout cas merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]